police in japan have arrested mark
capelas the ceo of a failed bitcoin
company
mount gox was one of the world's largest
bitcoin exchanges until last year
it lost millions worth of bitcoins
leaving angry investors without their
money
[Music]
i had no idea who was mark carpellis
some guy who has a first bitcoin
exchange and he's sitting on top of you
know almost a billion dollars worth of
money and where did it go
[Music]
this whole burgeoning ecosystem and
technology was essentially entirely
dependent on this you know 20 something
french guy sitting there in tokyo you
know with his cat
[Music]
all of a sudden this website just
crashes and burns seemingly out of
nowhere
there are up to one million accounts so
it's a hell of a lot of people out there
who've got reason to be angry
this is almost more like a wild west
robbery
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just imagine
imagine a bank you can trust a bank that
knows
imagine above all a world without banks
or bankers a world in which the
governments no longer control their
currencies or its value this new world
is a currency digital free universal as
easy to use as a credit card but it's
discreet as cash
and its name
is bitcoin
[Applause]
are you ready to bypass the system in
2008
this was a period of financial crisis
the system almost failed
again but the central banks came to the
rescue printed trillions of dollars to
bail out the banking systems and all the
the large the large mortgage holders
there were bailouts all over the world
it created this whole new desire to have
a financial system that existed
outside the bounds of
wall street outside the bounds of
central banks there was this desire to
kind of return
money back to the people
[Music]
at the time there was a small group of
people that were working on the idea of
a new digital money that would be
entirely private be not connected with
the government be global
and purely digital
the immediate reaction to thinking about
electronic cash is that it can't be
possible because if it's digital you can
make a copy of it if i make a copy of it
then aren't there two of them now like
it just
naturally wants to fit in your brain and
it was 2008 when satoshi nakamoto you
know which is a pseudonym for somebody
else or maybe several people we still
don't know
but came up with this idea of a ledger
and a ledger that would belong to
everybody that everybody could see
and there would be a protocol to enter
and exit the ledger and there would be a
very carefully scripted algorithm that
how many of this new unit called bitcoin
could be created when you start reading
about the blockchain and distributed
ledgers it just clicks like oh wow there
really is this way to do this
decentralized authentication of
transactions where you really could have
a digital cash system and then
it sort of turns on another part of your
mind to this whole world of
possibilities that weren't possible
before it was very apparent to me early
on that it was going to be a big deal
the very first product that i bought was
a pair of pliers
i didn't need pliers
but
that was the first thing and i was in a
hurry
so i clicked that and i said okay now um
scan this code
this qr code so i scanned it and sent us
some money so sent it and they said your
transaction is done and really the i had
a sense like a breathless sense they
didn't know my name they didn't have to
know my identity
uh it wasn't based on a trust
relationship they didn't have to access
my credit history
nothing matters except that i owned
something
so you have to understand
it was like
a cash transaction
except
the person i'm transacting with is not
in front of me the person is somewhere
else could be anywhere in the world
nothing like that has ever been possible
in the history of the world and when i
realized this i thought i can't believe
this i can't believe this just happened
so i got up and i remember just dancing
around my dining room table just kind of
like doing a little dance going that's
the future i just saw the future and i
realized at that moment if this works
the relationship between the individual
and the state and our whole public lives
are going to change forever
when i don't know but it's going to
happen bitcoin was really
fed by some of the same
[Music]
philosophical impulses as the internet
and also some of the same sort of
technological concepts as the internet
um you know both
are really on a technological level
about taking power away from the center
at the core the internet and bitcoin are
really about decentralizing power
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you study economics you realize the
more economic freedom people have the
higher their standard of living
if you or i print a bunch of money in
our basement and go around town spending
it we would go to jail for
counterfeiting because it's economically
destructive and is stealing from
everybody else when governments do the
exact same thing when they print a bunch
of money it doesn't change what it is
it's stealing and it's wrong for the
exact same reason and as a voluntarist
and a libertarian i have a huge huge
problem with that so the invention of
bitcoin strips that power away from
every single government in the entire
bitcoin could mean different things to
different people one of bitcoin's
strengths is that you know it had all
these different elements to it and
somebody could be into it because of the
political aspect and some of somebody
could be into it because of the you know
technological advances that it made
and you know everybody could you know
kind of have their own
connection
certainly in the first
few years the typical bitcoiner was a
guy who spent most of his life in front
of his computer
you know and not a whole lot of time
with other humans
but these were people who kind of lived
you know one degree or another sort of
in their own world and could inhabit
this abstraction which was this new
money
there was no reason to think it would
work and so you had to be a little weird
to devote any time to this
week
the technical
you know i got into economics because i
realized the quality of money has a lot
to do with the quality of our lives you
get the money wrong you get everything
wrong with bitcoin we have a chance to
get the money right
and it can liberate the world
at least a third of humanity is unbanked
today
this provides them financial power
access
a chance for a better life for everybody
equally
democratically
all over the world regardless of race
sex religion and nationality
that's awesome that's beautiful
that's
utopia to me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] itches
us libertarians we don't like uniforms
too much
of course when mark bought mount gox
he'd expect to end up four years later
handcuffed to the back of a cop car
did you mark
huh
and whatever beginning of 2011 mount gox
became the first credible internet site
to exchange dollars into bitcoins the
thing is at the time well a bitcoin
wasn't worth a buck so let's be honest
nobody really gave a [ __ ] but just a few
short months later the media dragged
bitcoin out of the shadows and mount gox
went from 3 000 to 60 000 clients in
just a matter of weeks and that
that was the beginning of the glory days
favre mark isn't that right
mark
[Music]
moun cox was the first place where you
could turn your fiat currency into
bitcoin it was the exchange there wasn't
really an alternative this was the mount
cox was the bank of bitcoin essentially
they had like 98 of the world's market
share if if you think of bitcoin as
being an island
at that time mount cox was the only
bridge to the rest of the economic world
the growth in mount cox was very quick
as we saw you know very large increase
in users
the first few months
after i joined it started changing and
we were getting a lot more structure and
actually we're seeing a lot of the
business side of the company
as time went on and big coins became
more valuable
people would leave larger deposits for a
longer amount of time in mount cox so
someone might have ten or fifteen
thousand dollars in their account at
mount cox and have it there for two or
three months while they were waiting for
a good time to trade for bitcoins so
mount gox became very popular very
quickly became very successful very
quickly mark was always a believer in
bitcoin and he really thought that um
you know this could do something and he
wouldn't want to make the company work
he was always like in front of a
computer late at night early in the
morning and you know
he'll be in the office for a long time
it seemed like he was always busy and
stressed out but that he was always like
doing something and trying to um
actually make bitcoin into something
very useful in the future because he
really believed in it and he did talk a
lot about his mongols is like you know
his his i want to say like his baby
[Music]
i think was trusted as the place that
people could uh manage their bitcoins
could manage their money it was the
website where everybody wanted to store
their bitcoin it was the it was the most
popular place
once you become the central bank of
bitcoin basically
you become a target
any bitcoin company was a
target for hackers i mean this was just
digital money that was just sitting
there this was kind of the simplest
bounty system in the world where you
know you got the password you had the
money but certainly mount cox was the
biggest of them all so it was the
biggest target
the news
we started using something called the
cold wallet which means that the
bitcoins in the wallet can only be
accessed from using physical means
that prevented hackers from ever being
able to access the cold war because they
would have had to have access to the
physical piece of paper that had the
secret
to be able to get into that wallet
so
bitcoins would initially go into the hot
wallet or the main wallet be kept there
for a little while and it would be
eventually sent to the cold war
bravo
really that was rich what fat mark
forgot to tell you was a lot of that
money he made was off guys like himself
too stoned to go to their dealers hey
talking about me
why should i freeze my ass off in the
streets with a couple of clicks on
secret i could have my [ __ ] delivered to
my door
silk road was this website that was sort
of incredibly
you know you could you could order drugs
as easily as you could order a book from
amazon the only way that they would
purchase drugs and other items on silk
road was by using bitcoin that was the
only currency that was accepted um you
couldn't pay in dollars you couldn't pay
in euros you couldn't pay using a visa
card you had to pay in bitcoin no credit
card no trace he pays in bitcoin
it's like he was a ghost
ugh
[Music]
no thanks
without mount cox i don't know
um you know if silk road could have been
what it was you know this was the way
that people turned their dollars into
cocaine you know this was the central
mechanism that made that possible the
silk road was probably the most
successful startup company
ever in the entire history of the world
it went from absolutely nothing to
probably billion plus dollars in in
sales over the lifetime of the silk road
wow congratulations i don't think that
uh
mark carpel has tried to become the you
know
bank the online bank to drug lords or
anything but that was certainly what it
became
is
[Music]
all of that popularity and success went
towards making mark feel he was
important
he was originally interested in
lamborghini for himself he also bought
himself a large house and then a
penthouse and all of these things
seem to say that he wanted to show
everyone that he was making money and
his status in the world was arriving
as that sort of thing started happening
more and more many of us started
becoming uncomfortable
and mark replied that his grandmother
owns a castle in austria and said that
if we
can't trust him then
there's nothing more for him to talk
with us about
there was no way to tell how much money
the company was making
how
large its expenses were or where the
money was going in the company because
mark was the only one with access to the
accounts
and he refused to share that information
with anyone else
he
always thought that bitcoin
because it wasn't a real currency none
of the laws really applied to
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is tigran gamberian i'm a
special agent with a restaurant
investigation we've been around for
almost 100 years and we go back to the
days of organized crime you know al
capone of course i have to put that out
there that was that was a famous irs
case you know we're always on the
lookout for emerging currencies or
methods of payment that could be used to
facilitate crime uh when a bitcoin came
out at least in the early days that was
kind of
like how do we even track this i mean
it's just numbers floating around in um
the bitcoin world and
to us that was kind of
it was a hurdle well government was just
starting to take notice of bitcoin and
uh like with a lot of new technology
it's it's unclear how how the law
applies to it no one really cared that
much until the silk road because you had
you know people selling drugs and
telling chuck schumer you can't do
anything about it all he can do is kind
of cry about it on the senate floor so
they started looking for ways to to
regulate it and how to make a statement
heroin opium cannabis ecstasy
psychedelic stimulants they're all
listed in the in the light of dead it's
unbelievable
and it's all hidden because they don't
use dollars they use this
surrogate currency
[Music]
i think it was in the spring of 2013
that the financial
crimes and enforcement network
uh put out a one-page
regulation just like one page and they
faxed it to everybody that said if
you're going to be exchanging dollars
for bitcoin and back again you have to
have a license getting this money these
licenses
cost more than a hundred thousand
dollars because you have to give a
license in every single state and it's a
that's a terrible regulation there's
lots of people in government that just
they get furious inside when they think
people are doing stuff without my
permission people are engaged in free
trade with each other without my
permission people are smoking or growing
plants without my permission they get
angry and they want to steal money from
other people in the form of taxes and
then use that stolen money to lock those
people that are growing plants without
their permission and lock them in a cage
or people that have a white powder that
makes them feel happy they have to lock
those people engaged this is madness
this is craziness just because it's a
new emerging technology doesn't change
the fact that you're still dealing with
money and there's still potential for
criminals to use your services the
reason that there are these laws is to
prevent that
so even if you have a new
company if you have this new idea great
do it
but you're still bound by the same laws
that are
in place for these types of businesses
which are money service businesses you
know or financial institutions the major
importance of the fincen ruling was is
that
before that
um you had a lot of people who still
wouldn't agree that there was any value
to bitcoin right like it was just
software software really can't be money
right and then this you know financial
crimes ruling comes out
and it says no really this this is money
it was it was just a different world
after that
at that time there's sort of a cottage
industry of
day traders people who are trying to
make money for themselves on the side um
by buying and selling bitcoin at one
point i did a story where i was talking
with some people in a chat room who were
doing this and it really sort of
surprised me the kind of range of people
that were doing it there was a business
student there was also a biology
doctoral student there was a bunch of
different kinds of people who you know
decided it was worth their while to buy
and sell bitcoin
that's when real silicon valley firms
andreessen horowitz union square
ventures in new york started to make
uh their first investments in this space
there was a lot of hype in the media
amongst journalists like trying to
figure out what bitcoin was so you know
i thought you know this is definitely
exciting this is definitely something i
want to be part of and since mount gox
was the largest player in the world i
thought you know what a great
opportunity to to get involved
with that bitcoin movement at the time
for creatives this is a dream come true
you have a company that's ostensibly
flush with money who has a huge customer
base in a a market that's
just beginning to explode has no brand
really everything needs to be updated i
mean
this is this is a dream come true it was
just heaven it was actually quite
exciting to be a part of this when i
spoke to people
in japan and abroad that we were working
on the gox
account and working with bitcoin
everyone was just fascinated it was
really amazing how much interest it was
from from outside you know from these
major vcs and hedge fund guys and high
net worth individuals in new york china
all around the world interested in doing
business with us not necessarily
investing in the company but buying a
[ __ ] ton of bitcoin it was let's make
something that's
[ __ ] amazing that everyone is going
to look at and say well this is the
exchange that we're going to uh put our
faith in
[Music]
the first thing that we did
we decided that
any press communications that came in
should go through me we all agreed on
that i come in second day like 9 00 am
first thing walk in the door and there
is mark sitting on that
blue ball
being interviewed by i think it was
reuters and i just walked in and said
what the what the [ __ ] is going on
what's what's going on in here what are
you doing and i said oh mark is being
interviewed by by reuters
we just discussed this like not even 24
hours ago and of course that ended up
backfiring spectacularly
that was the first time i'd seen mark
was the picture of
him on the ball and
immediately i looked at
the whole aesthetic of
this larger gentleman sitting on this
ball and thinking this is not
putting forth a message of
trust trust in us we would try to
explain to him you know
mark
don't bring your pizza into this meeting
with this important customer or mark
stop playing with the robot now you know
it's time to do some work and he would
just ignore you and keep playing with
his toy there was no cto there was no co
it was just
mark at the top and then pretty much
everyone else it was like the the widest
shortest pyramid
ever
evidently
[Music]
[Music]
my first uh you know official full-time
day at malgox
was
quite
interesting as well i remember arriving
and then it was one of the executives
just
plonked a bunch of papers on my desk and
said okay we're involved in like several
um sort of legal uh issues right now uh
can you like read these documents and
summarize them for us and at the time
remember thinking hmm
legal issues uh number one and number
two like shouldn't this be
given to the lawyer people crying people
not knowing what's going on people
backstabbing in there
people who would come and go the the guy
with the the big swirly scarf round
these stories about nails near throwing
stuff at the walls and shouting matches
and all of this all of the stuff that
was going on there every day it's like
you walk in there like i can't believe
like this
oh
we just thought this is just this is the
cream on the
on the top that chaos we just thought
no one's going to keep their job here i
thought eventually would we'll just be
replaced they'll grow so big they'll
need they'll need a global agency to
handle every everything that they're
doing but this will be a great story
ah ignorance is bliss a bliss so
complete it makes you forget your
obligations
obligations like you know compliance
with us government regulations
i need that chair buddy excuse me
just a few weeks after the new laws were
passed in the states the government
seized five million dollars from mount
gox's accounts now in and of itself not
a big deal for a company of this size
but little did they know ship is about
to get a whole lot worse
[Music]
and they weren't doing this from the
start they're supposed to take two forms
of id bank account information all these
things to verify
who the users are it makes a good
strategy for law enforcement if you can
get everyone roped into this one central
uh database then you just take that
database and go after the criminals
uh
um
[Music]
following the department of uh homeland
security investigation and the seizure
of our accounts in the u.s japanese
banking partners freaked out i remember
seeing the executives from the banks
visiting our office more and more
frequently and then over time they
impose limits you know in terms of the
amount of transactions we could do with
them per day
in terms of
the currencies that we can actually be
dealing with and which eventually um you
know enabled us to survive as a business
only on enabling um like transfers in
japanese yen domestically and when you
consider that more than like 95 of our
customers at the time weren't based in
japan and weren't transacting in
japanese yen this was a major major blow
to how we could operate the only way to
send people money was from the post
office that was it
[Music]
come on
[Music]
mark to his credit busted his ass trying
to
send money to people people did get
withdrawals
just real slow
[Music]
we wanted to communicate and say the
banks are screwing us but we couldn't
say that right because then
the bank could easily just shut down all
of our accounts and we would be screwed
we wouldn't have any banking partner in
japan our hands were kind of tied in
many situations where we wanted to
communicate i was concerned when there
started being fiat withdrawal delays at
mount cox so i agreed to make a video
for them and i i wrote the words myself
i read my own script and i chose my
words very very carefully and even to
this day everything i said in that video
is true
i regret having made it for them
i'm roger veer long long-time bitcoin
advocate and investor today i'm at the
mount gox world headquarters in tokyo
japan i had a nice chat with mount gox
ceo mark karpeles about their current
situation i saw that he had over 100
million u.s dollars in their bank
account that's a lot of money and then
he showed me a letter from the same bank
that all that money was held in
and that letter from the same bank told
them that they're allowed to send 10
international wires per day and they're
allowed to send about the equivalent of
a million us dollars domestically per
day
obviously that's not enough
uh for
for for a business of malcox's size to
keep up with the demands of their
customers i'm sure that all the current
withdrawal problems at mount cox are
being caused by the traditional banking
system
not because of a lack of liquidity at
mount gox for now i hope everyone will
continue working on bitcoin projects
that will help make the world a better
place
i discovered bitcoin in 2013 in april
2013 the market for bitcoin just went
crazy it went from 20
to 240
within a space of two weeks and the
price was jumping up and down by 50 or
double every day at that point i
realized okay trading is what i want to
do
uh so i gave up my free answer work and
i
started trading full-time march 2013
there were bank runs in cyprus and
that's when the price of bitcoin first
spiked and it went to about 160
and i was really kicking myself if i had
just you know made a simple investment
at 10
right i could have made a ton of money
and that's when i said that's it i'm
going to find a good time to buy i'm not
going to look back
and uh i you know i wired mount gox uh
some money and then i was in the game
so there was a period of
amazing excitement towards the second
half of 2013. bitcoin was going up from
it was hanging around 100 140 for a
while then it stayed around 200 for a
bit then it just started shooting up
nobody was really sure why and then the
silk road bust happened that's when i
got kind of nervous there was a lot of
speculation in the forums by people
about well is the price going to
collapse
what's going to happen to the volume on
the exchange and i think some people
started selling this was
i believe the end of october and i just
held and sure enough uh when november
happened when november 1st hit the price
started to go up and that whole month in
november it like it didn't stop and i i
had held the whole time and i just kept
holding i put my money on mount gox to
do some trading quickly realized that i
had no idea what the hell the market was
doing i shouldn't be trading uh
i just held and watched it go up
it was just rising like crazy so went
120 240 and just kept going up and up
and up and suddenly it was a thousand
dollars
i'd be in front of my computer just like
kind of cheering on the price it was it
was great
uh
yeah i go to the gym to work out and i
couldn't stop looking at my phone right
tracking what was happening it was it
was a wild ride and so at the end of
that month uh november i think the price
was around 1200 or something i i didn't
really want to sell my bitcoins yet but
i wanted to get them back off mount cox
after trading i asked for the coins back
and it was a slow response it was
actually my birthday i remember it very
clearly i was in paris in a hotel i
don't know why but i was thinking i
really should withdraw my bitcoins from
my gox i went to my computer and
started a withdrawal
and i checked an hour later and they
hadn't come out they told me i needed to
verify my account which they never asked
for before uh when just dealing in
bitcoin to receive a bank wire they'd
want it and that's when uh
things started to go
downhill
[Music]
customers were getting angry and angrier
sometimes you know even myself i would
be given like
transferred calls
um you know from people who would just
like shout and insult me on the phone
and that's when i started to to look for
uh you know
an exit or a way out because i realized
that
things were going to
to get
crazy
up until early 2014 uh mark had been
able to say i can't get dollars or yen
through to you because of these limits
that they're imposing on me but once
people couldn't take their bitcoins out
that pointed to a much more fundamental
problem because if he had the bitcoins
he could have sent them immediately and
a couple of days later i woke up and i
already knew i had to go there i think
my mind had decided while i was asleep
you must go to japan
there was a snowstorm that day in tokyo
there was literally an igloo on the
street of mount gox it was freezing
i went down there
there was the street was almost empty
i pulled out my sign and i felt
monumentally stupid
and then capela's suddenly starts
walking up the street the journalists
start scrambling to get their video
cameras out
and then i try and stop cappellas
to talk to him he has clearly no
interest in talking to me okay i came
all the way from london
all the way from london to try and get
my big clients from me to find out
what's happening no problem
he started launching into the standard
response oh sorry that is not possible
um there are technical problems but of
course as a techie i knew that there
were that a technical problem wouldn't
stop them giving bitcoins back
do you still have the bitcoin
do you still have everyone's bitcoin he
was pretty concerned about that question
um eventually he pushed past got into
the building and said don't come inside
i don't expect their company's going to
last much longer i think it's about to
collapse
and i expect that no one's going to get
the money back but we'll see
by that time i i just left tokyo
actually and had relocated back to hong
kong this was in
early february 2014
and i remember a friend of mine who was
aware of what was going on with man gox
called me directly and said remove
uh like any mention of man gogs from
your linkedin profile
and then i asked him like
okay why he said like just don't ask any
questions
just do it mount gox unexpectedly shut
down today one of the world's biggest
bitcoin exchanges has filed for
bankruptcy
bitcoins
the scale of it it was just so absurd
oman cox
in hundreds of millions of pounds and
prompting the sharp fall in the value of
the currency i felt like i had been
punched in the stomach and i couldn't
believe it
what the [ __ ] like
what do you mean that there's like no
bitcoin what do you mean we're missing
this many bitcoin how can you lose 800
000 bitcoin
you can't lose all of them before you
notice
that just seemed
absolutely insane if he had said like oh
we lost a few million dollars like you
lost a few million dollars are you
kidding me
now tell someone that you just lost like
800 million dollars
a billion dollars like at the peak it
was a billion isn't well over it now
and see
how they react
this is the problem with this whole
thing in general is that
people really got [ __ ]
on this right like
really badly i think people lost their
life savings
people lost
loads and loads of money and i don't
want to be seen as making light of this
in any way because but it's it's
it's just so absurd
i had
three just over 300 bitcoins in mount
gox which before they crashed the price
would have been worth about three
hundred thousand dollars of course after
they crashed the price it was worth
less than half that at the time that the
the bankruptcy announcement was made i
had been traveling around with some
journalists and they
we stopped around the mount cox office
and they heard words from some of their
fellow journalists that there was a big
announcement about to be made at his
press conference in japan i think he was
wearing a dark suit and i remember there
being a lot of microphones and the thing
that i took away from it was him bowing
a lot and which i guess is customary in
japanese business culture uh if you make
a mistake that you kind of make a big
kind of public showing of
um
saying you're sorry and apologizing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
um
um
people really want to know what happens
like what's the real story behind it
after the the crash
the
bitcoin let's say
ecosystem took a major hit
in terms of
respectability
public perception
even like for me personally i thought
okay well bitcoin is is dead like
there's no way that any governments or
banks will
tolerate something like this happening
again there's no insurance in bitcoin
there's no government backing for
bitcoin and obviously you know early on
that was the whole allure of this thing
was there's no government
uh meddling in this but as soon as there
were losses people realized oh there's
also no government to back this up when
i get my bitcoin stolen they're gone
that's it that's the end
[Music]
during the first half of 2014 a lot of
people started
investigating this and seeing if there
was anything that could be done well
there are
probably two reasons for why it can be
really hard to trace bitcoin despite it
being
inherently traceable first in the case
of mount cox
purely scale mancox had an immense
number of bitcoin addresses it's too
large for a human to easily see because
there's just so much information to take
in the other problem is that if you
deposit a bitcoin to a service like
bangkok and if you withdraw that bitcoin
later it's not necessarily the same
bitcoin you might have gotten a
different bitcoin deposited by some
other customer as a result uh when a
bitcoin is deposited to one of these
places you can't follow the trail of
that particular bitcoin
i think a lot of people at that point
just suspected that someone in mount cox
had stolen it
simply because there was no way to know
one way or the other i think the best
clue of what happened to those bitcoins
is that mark was able to find 200 000 of
them after
it was reported that they were missing
how many people in the history
of this world could actually claim that
they had accidentally misplaced 200
million dollars it doesn't chime
what is wrong with this guy you found it
under your mattress like what what what
are you doing you're a person who is
supposed to be running a company you're
a person who's supposed to have
experience in security or a person who's
supposed to be very knowledgeable about
bitcoin it was baffling to understand
like how you could just
lose that much money and then just find
it again
magically after the fact
[Music]
this pg-13 language i can only use here
or people were really pissed at them and
people hated them
i always felt that he didn't really get
the gravity of the situation it was just
terrifying to read what was what was
going on
[Music]
foreign
the question everyone wanted to know is
where are the bitcoins what happened to
them and at some point he went on to
twitter
and he started tweeting about things
like oh the sunrise in tokyo was nice
today everyone was still in limbo
waiting for him to
to say what happened to this half
billion dollars and he's talking about
the weather in tokyo
[Music]
i had been working at the the law firm
this guy came to us who was a former
mount cox employee nils nils arteshdod
he had a lot of information about mount
gox so he was very interesting to us
because he could give us a lot of
insight
and uh if mark had done something
criminal he was gonna
you know be a good source to help us
learn about it and help us prove it and
so he had this story about mark giving
him a death threat
i went with him i walked with him back
to the mount cox office i kind of looked
around with him but i and i believed his
story i did
and he seemed credible there was some
woman
for some from some bitcoin company who
died right she was in singapore i think
she fell off a building
there was rumors online that maybe that
was somehow connected i went and had my
apartment you know my hotel room moved
from like the the 10th floor to the
second floor in case i had to get out
easy it was kind of kind of kind of
scary but yeah most people speculated
that he was a total thief or a crook and
actually it was really hard to escape
that thought someone with that amount of
money and you know has a lot to protect
and you hear a story like this
uh it's believable and of course a lot
of people speculated
[Music]
to protect your anonymity we will
reenact this interview so do you prefer
to be a woman or a man come on will be
fine
[ __ ]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
japanese
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i have been in contact with mark
karpeles a few times but our
conversations have been very brief
sometimes when i've asked him direct
questions he hasn't responded at all or
has responded in a very elusive way we
were able to reach his mother she
herself said that she had no information
from him you know it's a bit strange
that he doesn't seem to have anybody who
he really trusts or that who he
communicates with he doesn't communicate
with his family he's divorced from his
wife he doesn't seem to have any allies
as far as i can tell
he lived in this
world of hackers where you proved your
worth
through your code you didn't prove it
through
you know what you wore or what you said
you did it by what you typed into a
computer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three or four times his wife came to the
office
crying and begging mark to spend time
with his son
and he just ignored her until she left
mark is
a very strange
strange person it's
easy to believe that maybe he has
some sort of mental illness asperger's
or
some other social disability
he is not like
most people and
he doesn't sort of have the human
emotional range that you expect of most
people he's kind of a
still character and so i think it's easy
to kind of imagine him as sort of
non-human form because he just doesn't
have a lot of the human traits that
you expect
situation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he moved to japan
seemingly because he was just interested
in sort of the japanese culture for some
reason he just sort of fell down this
rabbit hole of being interested in japan
and wanting to live in japan and really
took to that
[Music]
i think mark loved japan but i think
mark was still in the
you know everything is sparkly and shiny
and japan is a wonderful phase of his
life
[Music]
this is a guy used to leave his computer
on a park bench right
and was amazing people in japan would
bring it back not everyone is so kind
but i don't think he saw what was coming
i i think that one of the facts is
because he's not japanese
and
and he doesn't have a lot of street
sense i don't think he actually
anticipated that i'm going to
be grabbed for
the failure of this company and be put
in jail
and that's a hell of a wake-up call
[Music]
we
authorities in tokyo arrested mark
karpeles for allegedly falsifying
financial records in the mount cox
computer system by one million dollars
in 2013.
responding activity
foreign
master
yes indeed there's
strong evidence that this was needed a
bot running at man cox and then doing
these trades and furthermore
he was running without any real money
backing it so
definitely fraudulent this was clearly
a very interesting phenomenon phenomenon
a very suspicious phenomenon
and a strong candidate for what could
have happened to the bitcoins but
if you look at the later parts of wooly
in 2014
it suddenly flips around and
instead of fraudulently
buying lots and lots of bitcoins it
seems to be just selling them back to
the same bitcoin market and
roughly the same amount that it
initially bought it would sort of cancel
each other out or at the very least it
made us think that maybe this is maybe
this isn't the whole answer maybe
there's something else
i think it makes for a very uh
gratifying villain in this case
uh he's slightly odd and quirky uh he
seems out of place as here's this normal
socially awkward geek that runs one of
the biggest bitcoin companies ever it
should be swimming in money
and of course it makes for a great story
if he is also some sort of a master
villain that steals all the bitcoin and
makes everyone think someone else did it
so yeah i think
he just makes sense from a narrative
point of view that paint him as the
villain it makes perfect sense for a
detective story
but maybe not in reality
[Music]
[Music]
you know japan is a wonderful place the
japanese justice system is [ __ ] up
japanese prosecutors are not interested
in a fair trial they're not interested
in justice so karpos mistake may have
been that he believed the system is
about justice no it's about finding
someone to take the blame and getting
them convicted
and then
moving on the police
thought that if they arrest him on some
charges that he would
confess
but he didn't confess
and thus they kept rearresting him and
rearresting him
they still didn't confess
and i think by the time this whole trial
has gone over you still won't know what
happened to the missing bitcoins and
that's what really everybody cares about
[Music]
i know
[Music]
arrested for one charge and for one
another and for one another
is it something common in the japanese
system
if bitcoins had not disappeared
mark wouldn't have been arrested right
[Music]
to me it looked like the authorities
just wanted to get rid of this thing
right and in japan there's something
like a 99.7 conviction rate because they
arrest you and you'll go to jail and
then you'll plea bargain right you'll
just accept it and that's what happened
to mark he was pre-trial detainee for
months
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Music]
can you imagine when the police
interrogated him that they probably
wanted to go and commit suicide
like it'd be the most frustrating
interrogation ever you know it's like 23
days
uh
detainment in japan without even having
a lawyer without a phone call or
anything they hold you like 23 days and
so you know by the time 23 days comes up
like they've deprived you of sleep
they've slapped you around 23 days is
way long enough for bruises to heal for
example and
they could have made him a punching bag
every day and he just would have been
it's like stone cold because he just
wouldn't have
wouldn't have like reacted to it and
didn't did they charge him with
something else so that they could keep
him for another 23 days after that yeah
mark mark said actually they they said
his lawyer said before well when you
walk out they're just going to arrest
you okay so he just like walked
he was released he walked into the lobby
they arrested him again and brought him
back
accusations
of
foreign
foreign
i think it's a very
big and complicated case it has many
parts it's not something where you
instantly
grasp what the entire case is about to
some extent it might be the same for the
police in that
the case is so big and complicated that
you you'd forgive them for going for
something that looks a bit easier first
like mark karplus is being accused of
embezzlement and misappropriation
and to the police these are probably the
first things that you would find that
you might actually be able to prosecute
him for because
other parts of the case like the missing
bitcoins are so big and huge that you
would have to invest large resources
into investigating them and you might
never find a crime it might not be who
you thought it was for example and then
that amount of time would be wasted
so from their point of view you would go
for the low-hanging fruit first
of all
i was really concerned that there'd be a
real risk that this might not be
investigated thoroughly because there
might not be the necessary expertise in
the correct place in the police or they
might not be able to
to find the right people because it
might require some on the street skills
and you might need to know the right
people to hear this this or that rumor
or just purely a question of technical
expertise
that's when we sort of decided that now
we have to look at the blockchain we
have to try and match it
even though
it's a huge amount of data we have just
tried to attack it somehow if indeed all
the money had been stolen at once it
should have been very easy to discover
the transactions through which it moved
the problem is that there was no such
single transaction it seemed to have
been that between
autumn of 2011 and towards up to the
middle or the even the end of 2013 there
were bitcoins stolen in chunks over time
almost continuously throughout that
entire period we have no idea exactly
how they were gotten into the systems
maybe some combination of social
engineering or just plain hacking or
compromised code or
something but first and foremost
to do this particular theft you need
patience because
they've been doing it over
years
and quite slowly and deliberately and
been quite careful in how to move the
bitcoins out afterwards
several times in the past
distinctly suggested that they had a
very strong security system they had
very properly designed
cold storage and this suggested that
their security would have been good and
they thought very deeply about these
things but
you don't need to steal the cold storage
necessarily if you just keep draining
the hot wallet and this works only as
long as
no one at mount gox is actually
monitoring how much money is in the cold
storage how much goes in how much goes
out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if these people are to be caught then
it'll be because they made some mistake
of how they used bitcoin or who they
sent it to or something like that if
they did it flawlessly then there's a
good chance they might never be found
even if they find the person who's
responsible for the collapse of mount
cox and all the missing funds and the
bankruptcy
that doesn't necessarily mean that mark
will go free the system doesn't want to
lose face they see something clearly
went wrong someone has to pay some kind
of price
so i think right now they're at this
point where they're trying to figure out
well what are we going to do about this
they're buying time i think they're
still trying to build their case
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign there's a lot of suspects in the
collapse of mount cox and of course mark
is a great suspect himself
[Music]
however you know if you're trying to
figure out what happened to this company
where did the money go where are the
missing bitcoins i'm just suggesting
that there's a lot of people that we
would look at i don't think the police
have contacted them honestly because
it's a pain in the ass
we got
a
giant envelope full papers uh looked
like it had been sent from
close to where the police headquarters
were of all these documents relating to
mount gox and the buyout and
the takeover and amongst those documents
which was probably like 400 pages
was this back and forth between mark and
jed the original owner of mount cox in
which basically jeb is saying
oh you know i i forgot to tell you uh
that you're we're missing about 80 000
bitcoins there's a whole bunch of
different ways you could sort of make up
the difference good luck mark is just
thinking he's getting you know
a wonderful deal on like a solid gold
horse but he doesn't know that it's
basically a trojan horse that's painted
gold
in english we usually say a fall guy you
know someone to take the heat someone to
take the wrap uh a fall guy
um a sacrificial lamb i mean there's
many ways you could say it it's like oh
i got this company i'm really it's
really indebted if i don't get myself
out of this hole it could be a real
problem oh but here's this guy who wants
it so if he signs up and takes it on he
takes on all the debt too so it's all
mark's problem we have tried to reach
jed mchale several times
nobody seems to be able to find jib
and we know that it's alive
hopefully
running a business is a lot of
responsibility right and this is one of
the things that i did not explicitly did
not want to have here right because
there is a lot of risk in this kind of
business there's regulatory risk there's
like people are always going to try to
be hacking you and stuff like this it's
like
it's uh
a kind of headache that i didn't want to
have right so i explicitly looked for
somebody else to assume this
responsibility mark purported himself to
be this like security expert so he
seemed like a you know he had done he'd
done like lots of stuff with banks
before it just seemed like he would
actually be a good person to run mount
cox i don't think jed just wanted a fall
guy i think he wanted mount gogs to
actually work that's why you kept 18 or
sorry 12
if you just wanted a fall guy you just
sold the whole thing off jed wanted some
benefit without all the risk that's
that's what it was the bitcoin loss
actually happened after he took over
like basically i gave him access to all
the servers and then then like a week
later or something like that uh there
was someone compromised them and was
able to steal like from our hot wallet
essentially 80 000 bitcoin sounds like a
tremendous amount now and it is a
tremendous amount right now but back
then it wasn't a big deal right so
when mark bought the company or
got the company that was 80 000 bitcoins
worth maybe 20 000
that's a doable debt
but two months later when the price of
bitcoin surged up that is an 800 000
debt
and that is not something that mark had
that may have been the birth of willie
bot
williebot if i say
[Music]
that
um
for example
[Music]
is
buyer agrees to indemnify seller against
any legal action taken against buyer or
seller with regards to mount gox.com or
anything acquire under this agreement
okay well
it just says that uh mark's going to
indemnify
jed
if if any action is taken against
uh you know against jed regarding mount
cox it's not nondisclosure i mean he can
talk about whatever he wants to talk
about it's like pretty standard legal
clause where you know as a seller of
something the buyer identifies you to
make sure that they're not going to come
back to you later and be like sue you
for something that you no longer have
control over right
[Music]
jed had some real experience in the
technology world running things building
things and i think that gave him a sense
of his own limitations run by anyone
competent it would be a billion dollar
business like he totally just screwed it
up right
mark had done projects he'd done real
work but i don't think he had come up
against his own limitations probably
with bitcoin
you know he was forced to become
at least somewhat aware of them quite
quickly but i think
mark also had an ability to
blame others rather than to sort of
accept his own role in his own
shortcomings some people are good at
running a business some people are good
at coding some people are good at like
writing you know that people have
different strengths right and it's
it's unfair to expect someone to be able
to do all of it but it's not unfair to
realize where your weaknesses are and
like try to find people that can help
you fill in the gaps right and i think
that's that's part of being successful
is like knowing what you're what you
where you need help and like you should
get people to come help you with right
mark knew you know he learned i think
pretty quickly in the first few months
that it was a lemon and what the
problems were and that the
you know his passengers in the car right
the customers
he didn't tell them about those problems
and they ended up getting hurt
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm good good to see you again
come on in let's see
[Music]
may have been the most high profile and
devastating incident of its kind when it
came crashing down in early 2014
declaring that hundreds of thousands of
customer bitcoins worth nearly half a
billion dollars had gone missing
and now it's finally time to find out
how deep the rabbit hole goes
at least
865 000 bitcoins were lost on the
bitcoin side due to the numerous thefts
and incidents over the years the single
by far most damaging act occurred on
september 11 2011 when hackers who had
penetrated the main servers silently
made a copy of the hot wallet private
keys at least 630 000 bitcoins were
taken out through these private keys if
you imagine
making a small hole in the wall of the
bank vault
and it's enough to get your arm in and
you can grab any coins that you can
reach
what happened was
that throughout mount cox's history over
the next few years
enough funds passed through this hull or
within reach of the hackers that they
were able to take all of it until there
was literally nothing left the typical
pattern is that the coins are sent from
the compromised private keys and they're
sent from those addresses into a new
address controlled
by the thief a
big majority of all the funds goes to
the btc exchange not only is it funded
with coins stolen from mount cox but
also coins stolen from other exchanges
as seen in the
corner of the graph
other thefts flow into the same network
of money laundering there's stolen coins
from bitcoin again there's stolen coins
from bit floor
all moving into the same group
it's possible to connect a lot of this
activity to
accounts but of course the hard part
would be to then connect that to an
actual real-life person and
more to the point being able to do
something with that information that's
not the job of an independent analyst
like me all i can do is
dig up
the forensic evidence that i can and
then i pass that information along to
people who might be able to make a
difference with it
did your investigation had been related
to the mongbok case
i can't really talk about that right now
it's
a hacker group with a connected money
laundering what is your partner's
personal view on the mongoose case and
especially the potential theft of
650 000 bitcoins i can't talk about that
and all signs point to russia as far as
i'm concerned
do you think we'll ever find the guys
who've done this
i can't talk about that
so what what did you know that it didn't
tell us we shot jfk
[Music]
arrested alexander winnick accused in
bitcoin billions of dollars trout
according to bbc a 38 year old co-owner
of the btce exchange was arrested in
greece winnick is accused of more than
four billion dollars laundering it is
known that he had been charged with 21
counts including laundering stolen funds
from mtg ox no public comments have been
received from alexander vinnick experts
believe that in general this situation
is even positive for bitcoin
[Music]
too many people were
naive
you know you have to remember that the
early people in the bitcoin space they
were not sophisticated investors
monetary economists high flying
financial guys whatever
they're just really naive uh
code monkeys really just just nerds and
geeks nice people playing
so they didn't know they got robbed i
got robbed
[Music]
there are companies that do business in
bitcoin they have conferences they have
meetings they wear suits they exist i
think in the way that any other tech
startup exists and lots of companies are
trying to figure out how to integrate
bitcoin into their operations it has now
become
pretty much kind of almost background
noise to silicon valley
in the earliest days when i got involved
in bitcoin 99.9 of the people that were
on the first bitcoin forum there they
all saw the world so similarly to myself
and we're excited for the same reasons
but this this is the next step for
bitcoin if bitcoin is going to grow to
influence and change and improve the
entire planet
then everybody has to be using it not
just the early libertarians or early
computer nerds we need the businessman
and the bankers and everybody else has
to be involved we need everybody all
together so
change is sad but
it's part of life too there are a few
utopian schemes that manage to survive
the real world and you know bitcoin was
no different
even if it doesn't
you know fulfill somebody's
philosophical beliefs it works is it
quite inherently a bad thing is it an
evil thing no but it can be used for bad
things
everything from terrorist financing to
ransomware hacking public corruption
drugs drug trafficking organizations
that's the thing it's money now like as
a monetary economist or and even as a
technological enthusiast what you would
really like is for something as
wonderful as bitcoin to be handed to
humanity like on a cloud you know just
coming in here is your gift and
everybody will start using it you know
but that's not the way it happens
it has to enter in through
financial markets and become
economically viable meaning that it has
to
pass through this weird stage where
people are testing things and buying it
and selling it every technology does
this it was the same with railroads you
know back in the 19th century there were
all kinds of scams uh bankruptcies
injuries accidents terrible things
happen but at the end of the day
we got railroads and that's awesome
you know mark carpal issue is almost
like
a theoretical physicist put in charge of
you know
landing a man on the moon um
you know probably not the right man for
the job
i mean it must be frustrating to to be
mark and have once been one of the most
influential people in the world of
bitcoin have access to a huge amount of
money and now be
here in japan and limbo accused of
crimes he didn't really commit his
reputation destroyed no money and
certainly
not the missing 500 000 bitcoins lots of
people angry with him and he is just the
guy who got in a little bit over his
head
well at first i you know i wanted to
find him and punch him in the face
for losing the money and like everyone
and then
you know i i talked to him and i
i realized he didn't steal the money
and uh i said okay well
you know let's let's just
not be so angry at him and yeah it'd be
very difficult to be mark carpolis and
have to face the
face the press after losing everyone's
money
i probably would just never go online
again
if it were me
[Music]
[Music]
a
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
swami
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's the moral of this story
greg
yeah look i'm not i'm not sure what the
the moral is here apart from uh
you know you know if you're selling a
product make sure you've got that
product
before you tell everybody
we're open for business
[Music]
[Music]
i was born from 3.54
[Music]
megahertz xylo crosstalk
oh
motherboard or motherboard
by side i always feed
[Music]
check the rate gas you better wake you
too greedy losing your solar [ __ ] has
always been your boat full of cons when
somebody buy a house or a lambo try to
ride but don't forget
[Music]
new boys in the band but they don't
understand that in peace we rust but in
cruelty we trust